bang bang what's going on guys hope you
guys are really excited about this
interview i really enjoyed it i think
you will as well but before we get into
that make sure that you
like this video so that more people on
youtube can find it make sure you
subscribe to the channel
and don't forget that blockfi is the
sponsor today they've got three products
you can buy and sell crypto on their
crypto exchange you can deposit crypto
and earn up to eight point six percent
apy in an interest bearing account or
you can deposit crypto and take out a us
dollar loan against your crypto
collateral you can use the description
right here
or you can go to blockfi.com to learn
more
all right let's get into this episode i
hope you guys enjoy this one
all right guys bang bang i've got alex
from eight sleep here thanks for doing
this
yeah thank you for having me you're
living in miami now which is awesome
uh i feel like this is where everyone's
moving if you're not here where are you
um let's just start with your story so
we've had matteo on the podcast before i
feel like he
sits on twitter all day long does
nothing and just tweets non-stop about
sleep is important which it is
uh but you are one of the other
co-founders of the business
so what did you do before eight sleep
yeah so before
right before i'd sleep i was living in
new york
and i was working at a financial
technology startup it was really
a startup it was a really different
business we were targeting
building technology targeting
independent wealth advisors so
totally totally different space still
working very much kind of like
that side of you know marketing and i
was kind of the right hand of the
founder and ceo
and then when mateo came over and you
know we're married so we've been
together for like 10 years pre-ate sleep
and when he came over and said well i've
been thinking about this thing around
sleep and he was talking to max or other
co-founder around building the
technology
they eventually thought well we want to
bring this to market and we want someone
who can
build a brand and market it to consumers
do you want to join us and i don't know
what was going through my mind i think
it was young and naive
and i trusted them and i had never done
consumer products or anything like that
even though that was my passion it was
something i definitely aspired to do so
i left my
comfy job in finance in new york and we
all moved to san francisco to start the
company
and so you guys moved to san francisco
specifically to start the business yes
yeah we thought well it's like a
hardware company we want to be in the
middle of silicon valley maxwell the
co-founder was based there
and we thought well we want to be there
we want to network we want to meet
everyone we want to have that experience
we thought we were going to be there
forever we're like san francisco's the
thing that's a place okay let's pack our
things and
we did a year there it was very fun we
did a lot of amazing very much silicon
valley experiences but then we ended up
moving back to new york what is the most
silicon valley experience you had
i mean going through yc okay that is
literally
yeah that is it like you know you're all
grown up and you're like going back to
the
accelerator and whatnot but that was
great i mean it was an amazing
experience it really changed the
trajectory of the company how was it
being a hardware startup
going through yc which i think is mostly
known for kind of being a software
accelerator yeah we actually had applied
two times before and we had not gotten
in okay so two denials third time
charm yeah and it was really because the
third time at that point yc was trying
to get in more hardware companies
you know so that was key because we
really thought well we're probably not
getting in because we have this
business that first hasn't proven itself
because we hadn't launched the product
to market
and second it probably doesn't kind of
fit what most advice investments look
like
but eventually we got in which was great
and we got in after we had already
launched on crowdfunding so we did our
first product on indiegogo that was a
huge success we did over a million
dollars in pre-orders and so it was
probably easier for them to take the bet
on
these people who had never built a
hardware product because also like we
were not really
founders that had that background so
there was a huge risk um but it was
super fun to get in there was a
small group i probably at our badge
maybe 10 of companies were hardware so
you know
there were a few of us and we were
pretty close and like there's still a
bunch of us that are still alive and
thriving and growing but
um it was great it was like really fun
to be around other people who were kind
of building the same
type of product how did you get a
million dollars in pre-sales oh my god
it was insane
i figured it was all right so like this
is a company with no brand nobody knows
about it you have to convince people
sleep is important like there's so many
uphill battles there how do you do it
yeah that was really the first big test
i was super nervous because it was you
know very few of us and
we i was in charge of like launching
this crowdfunding which i had never done
and getting all these orders and so i
spoke to as many people as possible who
had done it before and you know at that
time this was like early 2015
there were a bunch of companies in
hardware that had found success in
crowdfunding
so there were people you can talk to you
know and ask them questions around like
how do they do it what did they focus on
and so we probably spent while max
and like the like one or two engineers
we had on the team were focused on
building
the prototypes of the product and
testing and all that i was focused on
building the campaign
so it was probably four months that we
spent doing that
and that was just like 100 of my time
just what's a strategy we knew we wanted
to get to a million because there were a
lot of companies had gotten there so we
thought we could make it
and the first thing that we did was talk
to as many people as possible about
their sleep
so we had this apartment in san
francisco and that was our office
i was on second street and so mom this
is not your apartment this is this well
no this was our apartment
this is where martina were living so we
were living in the office okay and then
the the
the our bedroom was a demo room that's
where we would put all of the new
technology
like god forbid that the engineers built
something that would like i don't know
shaka's or something in the middle of
the night we were trusting them they
would put every new prototype on our bed
so we were the first people to try
it and then in the morning our team
would arrive and we were like five
people and they would arrive and
everyone had a key
because so we had to be up and ready by
like somebody um some people were
reviving very early
and then we would work in the living
room so we just like moved all furniture
and like that was where eight sleep
started
amazing so that is where we launched our
crowd funding
and um we one of the things that we did
before that was talk to as many people
as possible about their sleep which was
kind of funny because at the time there
were no
like sleep companies know that some of
the beds in a box were starting and so
there were some conversations around
sleep but
not in the way that we were approaching
it we're like hey tell us everything
about your sleep what are your problems
what can we fix for you just you know we
knew that from
the reason why we started was because
matteo had had his sleep problems but we
didn't know if other people had the same
problem so we had to discover that
and so we would bring as many people as
possible into that office bring them
into the bedroom show them what we were
doing and then ask them questions and
then people start opening up
it's like hey i have different
preferences of temperature with my
partner and i struggle to fall asleep i
toss and turn a lot
i don't like the comfort of my bed like
whatever would come up we were just like
absorbing it
and then as we started crafting a pitch
for our product
then we would bring it up to them and
say like hey what do you think about
this
and so we were basically doing our own
like customer discovery and at the same
time like this sort of market validation
to understand how we should position the
product we had at the time
so when we launched on indiegogo our
pitch was we were making a mattress
cover to make any beds smart
uh got it which is you know super
product driven
very techie very different from what we
talked about today
um it was almost one of the biggest
learnings actually that i've had in the
process of building eight sleep as a
brand was
that sort of transition between talking
about it as a product like
make your bed smart and more like hey
achieve sleep fitness
you know like what's the benefit in the
end for the end user
and not just like what's this geeky
product which that worked amazing on
indiegogo because the community
definitely responded to it yeah yeah and
what do you think drove that like change
right was it just talking to people and
then telling you like hey stop talking
about like a smart bed and
and something else or was it just over
time as you guys kind of refined the
pitch like yeah
there was two things one it was because
that pitch stopped working
so eventually like ourselves platoon you
know post yc we actually then
um matto max moved to china they built a
team there we started manufacturing we
had to ship all those pre-orders
how long are they living in china oh my
god they probably did like four months
okay yeah um and we hired a team there
and you know
the people in our team um that started
with us what five years ago are still
with us
wow um there so they then
taken took over in the process and they
came back but
all the while they were in china i was
still in charge of
continue to sell continue to bring in
revenue for the company
and it started becoming really hard
because we probably went beyond that
like super early
techie adapter that supports something
on indiegogo right and so we start
struggling like and that's when you feel
like you're pushing this huge boulder up
a hill
right and like becomes really hard and
eventually
we um probably it was i don't know a
year after
we shipped our units we raced around
with cosla
so keith came on to our board and which
is rocket coastal ventures yes
and one of the things the first things
that
he told us is that we had to change the
positioning of the company
so he had that vision and and i think it
was one of
these other turning points for us good
guy to listen to
100 and you know it's hard to take it
because when you are so close to your
company
you think you know how to talk about it
and you've also seen that work in the
past
and so the ability to just take a step
back and look at it from a different
side and say well maybe that worked but
does that mean that this
can actually continue to work in the
future and it's kind of personal right
it's like someone telling you like you
should change your hair
like you need to change how you talk
about your company yeah otherwise you're
going to fail
and did you know exactly what to go
change the positioning to or did you
have to test that
many times so we didn't test it we went
through a very interesting process where
we knew that what was happening at the
time is we had that product that we
launched in crowdfunding and then we had
launched a smart mattress version so we
were kind of the first in the market to
introduce a smart mattress
and what started happening is the smart
mattress started selling better than the
accessory product because it was
probably an easier concept to grasp
right like people buy beds people go
online and they search for a mattress
people don't go online and search for a
smart mattress cover
and so we had a very specific um
place where we could land in terms of
like just retail categories
but then people started thinking was
this a smart mattress company
like oh this is a company that makes
mattresses but they make them smart
and there were a lot of companies
building mattresses in the market many
of which
at the time wanted to license our
technology wanted to acquire us right
because what we were doing was
interesting
but we didn't want to get bucketed with
them because that's just not who we were
we respect what they do and what they do
they do it really well
but we were born because we believe
technology can help people sleep better
we want to use deep tech to help people
sleep better
okay so this is a good segue for a
second uh right now
people see it as a mattress um you can
buy either the mattress or you can buy
what you call the pod which is basically
something that goes over an existing
mattress
um and people look at it and they're
like oh this is amazing i sleep on it i
can make it hot or cold it's like this
thermo regulation which is a word i
learned from you guys
i feel smart now and uh it makes you
sleep better right and
uh when i first i think the very first
time i talked to mateo
he told me he's like i'm gonna make it
so that you can literally sleep in six
hours i feel like you got eight
and i was like you're crazy and then as
i've gotten to know you guys
uh now i've invested in the business and
kind of really understood it
there's this whole vision of the
mattress is just a starting point right
so maybe kind of just walk through like
if we fast forward 25 years from now
like what is that thing that you're
trying to build so that people kind of
understand the difference between a
mattress company
and then this like sleep fitness company
yeah yeah so that's why you say we're a
sleep fitness company because we are
building
technology for sleep fitness and sleep
fitness is you know how do we make you
get you to that state of overall health
and well-being that is fueled by optimal
sleep
so the way that we see it if we think 25
years from now we obviously want anyone
in the world to be sleeping on a pod on
our technology
and what that technology will be able to
do is to give you
the best recovery possible every single
night to the point where it's so
optimized that you could potentially
sleep
six hours and get the same level of
recovery you're getting now if you get
eight hours
which is wonderful right because the
average american sleeps like six hours
and 40 minutes a night so most people
are not making enough time for sleep
anyways
so how can we compress it how do we
optimize it and that can be done through
a lot of things around the environment
right through the temperature regulation
through
light noise oxygen control etc so
there's a lot of things that
like physical technology paired with
real-time data to personalize it around
you
can achieve and then there's this other
side of it which is well
sleep is a core part of health you're
spending a lot of time in bed even if
you're spending six hours every night
what else can we do while you're
sleeping to save your life
and that's kind of what someone recently
on twitter said eight sleep has this act
one which is sleep act two
is is health and that really is the long
term like the future of aids sleep
because
while you're in bed there are many
things that one we already collect about
your health right now where
we track seamlessly without you wearing
anything your heart rate at rest
respiratory rate heart rate variability
uh we could see with that data things
like arrhythmia sleep apnea
snoring so anything any conditions
around like rest that would show in your
respiratory biometrics or your heart
rate
um but there are other things we can add
physically around your bed around your
bed frame
to do other things can it scan you your
body can it do an ultrasound
uh can you use radar technology to
identify things that may be growing
inside your body and your tissues and
your muscles inside your organs
so there's the technology that's being
developed by many other companies not
necessarily aid sleep right but like
it's already there it's proven
we can bring it into the eat sleep
ecosystem and start
doing health diagnostics or
um building a blueprint of how your
longevity is going how your health is
evolving as you age
which is kind of a really new concept
for people to think about their beds and
that's why we focus on sleep now but
that is going to happen eventually i
think the two things that
you know as i've thought more about it's
like okay like what are you guys doing
differently than most other people right
and i always
joke that outside returns come from
literally doing something different and
being right we'll see if you're right
i think you are but we'll see um and
there's two different things are one
uh this belief that um
you can actually use the dead time
right so if i sleep let's say eight
hours a day right that's one third of my
life
i'm going to end up sleeping all right
if i'm literally just sleeping
that's not very productive right it's
productive for me from a health
perspective but
there's nothing else happening what
you're essentially saying is like well
what can we do to you while you're
sleeping that is not disruptive to your
sleep it may actually enhance your sleep
and also can provide other values so
this is the whole idea of uh can we
scan your body can we you know do
certain things that
are health related that doesn't require
you anything other than hey go to sleep
but we'll provide all of this other uh
kind of output the second thing is in
order to do that
you guys are thinking about kind of
sleep environment not as
the bed right most people think of it as
just a physical bed that you lay on
maybe they get really crazy and they
think about like oh i should have some
like black out blinds to make it dark
right but like that's pretty much the
extent and and maybe like the uh
401 level college course is like hey
have like some music or something
to sleep too right but there's just
really not that much what you guys are
really thinking about is everything from
you know the oxygen in the room right
and so when you start to think about
like the nuance and kind of the
intricacies of that
you start to say like well what would it
almost be like an elite athlete if you
were gonna put them into an environment
and say
this is the absolute perfect environment
for full recovery uh
so that you can compete at the highest
level with your physical performance
well there's literally um what
hyperbaric chambers
there's you know oxygen uh injections
like all kinds of crazy stuff that
happens
but that is so expensive and so hard for
anyone to replicate at home
yeah what if you can commoditize that
and then bring it to a kind of a mass
consumer audience right exactly
and to me like if that happens you
literally change the way that
humans are productive because you can
literally
drastically increase their output when
they're awake yeah that's the bet
exactly that's the bet is like people
who embrace eight sleep right now are
because they want to improve their
performance whatever that they do
there's a lot of pro athletes that sleep
on it a lot of
celebrities and ceos and investors but
it's more than that right it's like
there are a lot of
say average people who are looking to
feel better
during the day and that they've come to
understand that sleep is important for
that
and eventually what ate sleep as a brand
is building
is a movement where how do we bring that
same level of like
knowledge and consciousness around sleep
to other people who may not realize yet
that sleep is that important how do we
educate them how do we bring them to
join this movement and eventually
they will embrace our technology and
that technology will give them great
recovery
and eventually could save their lives
yeah and it's pretty crazy when you
start to think about this whole idea of
like scanning the body
right and you could literally say hey
there's something wrong
you should go get it checked out right
and then doctors can start to use this
information like all kinds of stuff
um all right how the hell have you guys
built this brand
right so i think that most people at
least on twitter have heard of eight
sleep
uh you have a good
fast-growing business but you're not
some incumbent that's got you know
multiple billions of dollars to deploy
from a marketing campaign every year
how do you kind of punch so far above
your weight like how have you guys done
this
yeah so we go back to that story where
it was
i don't know 2017 2018 i get lost in the
timeline but we bring in coastal
adventures we're bringing keith he joins
our board and he says you need to
reposition the business
and i i go back to that point because
that determines so much of what we do
now as a brand
um we went through this repositioning
exercise with this approach
that is a sort of like dna based
approach where you go and look back
inside the company
and you look at why you started now
there are many
um theories out there and like how do
you position a brand how do you build
that and there may be the ones that go
and test it and go and find
the open white spaces and markets and
they put in different decision
statements in front of customers and
they asked for feedback right for us it
was from the inside out it wasn't from
the outside in
and i think that has a lot of value i
really like that i think that's very
authentic
and so especially when you are a
business that is still guided by the
founders
that makes so much sense because there's
a reason why these founders took the bet
of starting that business and so there
must be something that's really strong
within them of like
why they want to build this company so
what really came out of that exercise
for us
is mateo's original kind of vision of
what sleep could be and why technology
can be valuable for sleep which you just
summarized right it's like
the ability to use technology to
personalize everything around the
environment what that means for sleep is
like you could sleep better you could be
fully optimized
and that would mean better recovery and
because he had
this passed as an athlete himself when
he was young he was a competitive ski
racer a better tennis player he was a
race car driver
there's always been this sort of a bit
of like performance athletic edge
to how he has built the culture of the
company not necessarily a company for
athletes
it's just the the mindset of like
thinking like an athlete a person who
always wants to
be better who invests in their body who
takes care of themselves right so
with all of those thoughts in mind then
we came up with the category
of sleep fitness we defined that what
we're actually building was not really
something in just like the sleep space
in general which you know if you look at
that space there could be a lot of
companies in bedding mattress
pharmaceuticals and
all those things a lot of services for
sure but that we were in this sort of
other space and we wanted to build our
own space and category of sleep fitness
and
we love the idea of building our own
category because it makes it really fun
to kind of set your own rules
we then embrace that concept and we
brought it into everything that we do
and how we talk about
the company right we have a sleep
fitness score and we defined what is
that how is it measured and we work with
our scientific advisory board for that
and to understand and how to
also like bring it into the fundamentals
of how actually the science of sleep
um works and it took a long time to get
to where we are now in terms of like you
said people on twitter knowing about
eight sleep
but the biggest things um that drove
that
were our consistency staying very
consistent in how we speak about the
business we are health and wellness
company focused on sleep fitness we use
technology to help you sleep better and
just
staying very on on brand right and like
saying the same message
everywhere where we could and everywhere
we were going to talk about the company
how we were talking about it on our
website how are we talking about our
products
and the second is product love like
there's not much you could do like if
you're building a brand but people don't
love your product
it's not really going to go that far
unfortunately so you just want to make
sure you're also focused on that as you
think about
making something people will talk about
yeah and it feels like you've really
leaned into this idea
that turning the customers into the
marketing team right
everybody who sleeps on it they're
screenshotting the app they're posting
it
uh i see mateo every morning he's going
and commenting
and and kind of being competitive like
what was your sleep score last night
i know that you've posted many many
times about just like what people are
actually doing with it and you have all
these great customer testimonials
how much of that is like you have to
tell the customers to do this versus
just like literally their product is so
good that they love it and they want to
go do this
at the beginning when we first launched
the pod which was in 2019 that was the
first version of the pod and that was
also another kind of turning point for
the company
um we we didn't have to
ask people or we didn't really ask
people but we had
some early adopters who loved the
product so much
that would do it for us so they were
kind of in a way because they had a
personal connection to us or maybe
some of them were our investors right
they were kind of those early advocates
that really supported us out there and
maybe they had a decent enough following
that other people were listening
and then what started happening which is
interesting and i'm sure many other
companies have seen that
is that then other people catch on to
that you know they see that there may be
this
influential person talking about it and
so maybe they want to talk about it too
because it says something about who they
are
i think that's one of the other very
interesting things about building a
brand as a movement is like you want to
build something that people want to up
themselves into
they want to be a part of because it
says something about who they are
and that's definitely how we think about
aids sleep like if you sleep on a pod it
says something about you
um it says that you're a certain type of
person that wants to achieve certain
things
take care of themselves um probably
wants to perform better
probably a little bit competitive
probably somewhat athletic or into
fitness into health
and so that's why people are so open to
share their sleep stats to say that they
sleep in a pod
um because they believe that they're
part of something bigger than just the
bed they sleep on
it's almost this like identity um that
they've been able to incorporate
literally a physical product but it's
not so much the product itself is what
the product stands for
correct right yeah um okay now you
supercharge this
with uh i'll call them marketing stunts
that probably cheapens what actually you
guys are doing
um the one i want to talk about is
during miami tech week which
uh i don't know what the official miami
tech week is at this point i know
there's a bunch of debate about this
but uh there's a bunch of parties
recently
and um one of them was at a house on the
venetian islands for those that aren't
familiar with miami it's
literally an island that i don't know 30
40 houses uh
on and it was in the backyard which is
right up against the water
and we're all there there's a couple
hundred people and next thing i know
there's a float that floats on over and
it just has a massive like lcd screen
and literally there's an eight sleep ad
that ends up being on this lcd screen
uh that was cool but then later on
there's a photo that starts to circulate
uh on twitter and the photo is basically
this person who hosted the party has
like a neon sign i forget what it said
exactly in their backyard
but you somebody took a photo with the
neon sign and then behind it is his
eight sleep ad
and it was like this like you know great
photo that everyone wanted to share and
be like hey come to miami miami is great
whatever
how does that come about like that is so
such a
good moment how did you guys do that it
was it was fast
it was one of those ideas that you're
just like okay should we do it or not
this is kind of crazy does it make sense
does it distract us right
as a startup you're doing a million
things every day and you have bigger
fish to fry
every day or so you think but it was
mateo he had this idea he was just yeah
like driving around his vespa in miami
like he does because he's italian
and we'll talk about the best book and
so he saw floating billboards on in the
bay
and um this party was coming and you
know it was kind of this this
big thing and we knew that there were
going to be a lot of interesting people
there and he thought well what if
could we put a voting billboard in front
of someone's like
private residence which is very
different than just running them on the
bay
and do we ranted by the organizers of
the party and they said yeah do it do it
like don't ask for permission just do it
and we we did it and we did it
but i literally know exactly who said
that and so that was the only person
that knew that was going to come up
oh they were the only person yeah yeah
no one else knew we're like we kept it
secret and by the way this isn't the
person who owns the house
no no no no so we thought about that
really well is the owner of the house
gonna get kind of like mad at us because
we're covering the view you know if you
want to show of their homes
and what view they have but ended up
being fine people loved it and they
remember it
yeah and so one of the things i've heard
people say before
and i think it's fascinating it's almost
like the reason why you would buy a
billboard right just like let's say in
times square or wherever
it's not actually for the impressions of
people in the build uh in times square
at the moment
it's for the photos that then go online
and they get the virality online
that felt almost similar here right it's
like hey there's this thing it's almost
like a
kind of like a party trick right where
people like oh look at this thing you
know whatever they take a photo and then
they share it online
and that's exactly what happened my
question is who took the photo did you
guys get them no
no that was not us no i don't know
somebody took that original
photo but yeah it was interesting and
and that is the whole point is what
you're saying there's a lot of brands
that have done it very successfully
where maybe they
brand coffee cups right and then people
take like a photo of their cup
like there's so many ways to do it we're
like how do you insert yourself into
culturally relevant moments because the
other thing that we thought about is
well what do we say in that billboard we
are a brand that stands for sleep
fitness i mean
i go to bed every night by 10 p.m we
were just talking about it right so
i sleep might eight to nine hours i
don't stay up late
i probably left that party at like 10
p.m that night which was like late for
me
so i'm not going to put a billboard
there there that's going to make you
feel guilty for having fun
right so it also has to play into
something that's relevant for the crowd
without it being like the party pooper
brand that's telling you to go to bed
now
yep so there's a lot of considerations
to have what did we say it said
some nights are worth a late night ah so
age sleep's kind of giving you this
a lot of people to party sleep in a pod
so it's giving you permission to stay
hey stay up late have fun some nights
are worth it how many nights like this
are you gonna have and you want to make
the most of it and yeah maybe tomorrow
you'll catch up on your sleep fitness
so uh one of the first times uh planning
on myself you and mateo go to
dinner um we get i don't know about
halfway through dinner that we met
around like 7 7 30
and all of a sudden i don't know mateo
very well at the moment i don't know you
super well at the moment
uh but i can just tell like mateo is
getting like
like antsy right and i'm like is he
excited about dessert
like you're like what's going on and
then i realized
he's literally checking his he's like i
gotta go cause i gotta go to sleep
yeah and i it just it it was amazing to
me of like
people who don't know you guys i think
are like oh yeah asleep what like
whatever but like
you're very very regimented right you're
really serious about this
uh you test all of the products right
some people may have seen online like
literally i think there was one where
you were like hooked up to a bunch of
machines before you went to sleep
and so like how much of this is just
you're building a company that serves
yourself
versus oh we think there's a need in the
market or are those two things the exact
same
they're kind of the same so what was
interesting is when i
started like in my early years with
eight sleeping i was young i don't know
i was
24 or 25 and i've always been a good
sleeper so it wasn't something that was
solving my problem right like i fall
asleep in a second i sleep pretty well
but the more i started learning about
sleep and the signs of it
and you know you read the research and
you read the books and
you see it in the data you realize
really how valuable it is
right and and you see that if you invest
in your sleep now it's going to pay huge
dividends in the future
not just in how you're feeling today so
you want to make that investment
and so for me it's also kind of personal
and that sounds like it's the best
thing i can do to take care of my health
i prefer to have a good night's sleep
than working out if i have to sacrifice
a workout
for a whole week because i need to just
get more hours of sleep for that week
every single night
that is actually better for you sleep
should come first people don't realize
that
interesting you grew up in mexico yeah
uh where i grew up in tijuana okay
i can't say it like that so i'm gonna
let you say it tijuana is okay
um for those they don't know tijuana is
not like the greatest place in the world
uh you've told me some stories about
some pretty crazy stuff like
literally uh as a young kid people are
trained to
not go certain places or hey here's what
happened if gunmen show up
uh i think one time you told me like
people would literally check twitter to
see like where shootings were happening
in streets whatever
what about your childhood do you think
kind of like prepared you
for actually building a company right
because i think what's so fascinating
about
you and mateo specifically i know
youtube best out of the company
is neither one of you are from the
united states yeah you both have
very kind of distinct and different yet
um interesting backgrounds and kind of
journeys to starting the business
but when i look and i say okay like who
are these people it makes a ton of sense
right it's like how do you think about
like your childhood coming to the united
states
all that in terms of like helping you
build a business yeah i grew up in
tijuana
for 18 years of my life so i left when i
left for college
and i honestly had a great childhood i
think i was just
privileged that i you know grew up
middle class my dad was an entrepreneur
my mom was a physician
um and as i when i was young
you don't realize when you're young you
know your parents are kind of taking
care of most things
but as you start becoming older and your
teenager you want to start going out
with your friends right you kind of
start learning the tricks and what i'd
say
is certainly the part of toronto i grew
up and was was great it was safe
thankfully you know knock on wood
nothing ever happened to my family but
when you start growing up and
expanding your horizons within your city
um you realize that you always need to
be
cautious and so you learn a lot of these
sorts of tricks right which i think what
then it translates into as an
entrepreneur is you become very kind of
resourceful you have to
figure [ __ ] out all the time like what
are some of the tricks well
i think there's there's things around
making things happen when we grow up in
a country that certainly is plagued with
corruption
in general as it happens in mexico um
there are there's
no is never an answer there's always a
way to get things done
right and so you learn that and it's a
way of life it's a way of life
yeah and if you don't operate in that
way of life like you're never gonna get
things done
and so that just becomes second nature
to you or like there will always be a
way for me to figure this out
who else can i talk to um and and to me
that's something that's so natural now
where like when i'm
faced with a problem i always think well
there must be another solution and i
really think it comes from growing up in
that environment and obviously you see
it in your parents too right because
that's the way they operate that's how
the way they build their businesses and
everything else
um so that is the one and then the other
key trick obviously is around like
personal safety which
when you then start traveling when you
start living alone as a young woman in
many other places
it just it's also second nature to you
because that's how you grew up
right from how do you dress with things
you carry showing off you know
just all of these sorts of things are
part of how you live
when you live in places like this and
tijuana has gone through many different
waves where you know
the city has been great and maybe it has
gone through tougher times and so
you just learn to adapt and you change
your life as well which
for us in 2020 adapting to just maybe
being at home and not going out and not
going out to parties now going out to
dinners
was normal actually my last year of high
school was kind of like that because the
city was going through a really tough
time there were
a lot of difficult situations with
cartels fighting for territory and
whatnot and so
we couldn't really go out to like clubs
you know you're
legally you go into mexico when you're
18 but like we couldn't do it
and so you have to get together with
your friends at home and you have to be
careful which treats you take at night
to go get back to your own home because
there may be
things happening so um you build the
sort of resilience and
ability to adapt to any circumstance
because the world around you is really
crazy
it's kind of this magical surrealism
that just occurs in
in places like mexico and a lot of
countries latin america as well but it's
almost
you know what's crazy to me it's like
it's just again a way of life it's a way
of life like i think people
the word cartel in the united states
they think like
narcos and uh what they've seen on
television and they're like oh my god
this is like horrendous
and then when you actually learn about
it it's almost like wait a second this
is almost like a shadow form of the
police
yeah right like to some degree right and
it's its own business right it's its own
operation it's a business that exists
there
certainly when you grow up in tijuana i
remember very clearly when i was a child
and my mom would ask like there was
maybe a neat kid in school and maybe
like you're becoming friends like
what do their parents do and
at the beginning i would think my mom's
just kind of being elitist or something
you know but
then i realized that she was doing this
out of safety because you don't want to
become friendly with anyone who may have
any ties to
you know which there are people like
that in the city and they have money and
so they end up putting their kids in the
good schools and so
it happens and is it you don't want to
become friends with them just because
you could get caught up in something
association you may be you know there
were a lot of stories
growing up like you may be at the wrong
party you may be
in the wrong home as a kid if you're a
kid and you go to somebody's birthday
party for example
and then all of a sudden there's a best
situation yeah it's um it's just a very
different life
right uh the other thing is you and mate
are married
uh planet and i work together a lot uh
and
we over time have learned how to do that
well and enjoy it etc
you guys not only work together you live
together in the same house
and the one of the first things you guys
ever told us that i was like wait what
like how did they do that
is you actually do your one-on-ones
on zoom yeah so i want to pick on that
specific
thing because i think it is a perfect
example of like
the way you guys have structured the
business right and so most people who
know anything about remote work
know that if you're gonna do remote kind
of optimized company
everyone has to act like they're remote
and so usually it's in an office right
everyone should be on the computer don't
have you know
80 of the meeting in person and then 20
percent of people calling in it's kind
of is this weird thing
[Music]
but literally you guys are in two
different rooms in the same house right
doing this so
walk through like how you think about
operating the business
uh being married also living together
and
now everyone goes to remote within a
year like there's just so many moving
parts there and it could be super
complex but it actually feels like you
guys have not only navigated it well
but actually have optimized the business
you know in this new environment
yeah so before starting eight sleep
matuna had worked on a bunch of like
things on the weekend like we never
talked about it we never said well are
we the type of people who are going to
build business together it just
happened and we have different skill
sets and so we were just kind of
complimenting each other we were coming
up with ideas it was usually him coming
up with ideas because like his brain's
just on
all the time he drives around his best
buddy yeah and he's just like thinking
about stuff all the time like what if we
do this or we do that i love that we can
make fun of him and he's not here to
defend himself
but yeah it's like australia
and and so we were building things and
um
we were just yeah having fun it was like
things that were going nowhere and then
eventually he had this idea of eight
sleep so when we started the company
and i mean it was it was him and maxwell
the co-founder and he invited me they
said well do you want to join it was
actually interesting was max who invited
me
because it was different coming from max
than coming from him right got it
um had the conversation with me and said
like do you want to do this and we
talked about it and everything so i
still remember that
and did you appreciate that it was max
or did you i definitely appreciate it
because you know it's it's hard if it's
like it's the two of them
you you may you may not know if it was
matteo pushing to have me on board
right so it was important for me to make
sure that max wanted me on board that he
didn't feel like he was compromising
just because
yeah i was there i was exactly um
trust me i'm pretty sure they're very
happy that you
and i'm very happy to be with them and
that was one of the key things for me to
join them actually and i was very honest
with them upfront i said
i have never done what you're asking me
to do i know i have certain skills to do
it and i have a passion for it
but i'm doing it because i trust you
because you're trusting me and if i ever
cannot fulfill what we need out of this
role i'll step aside
right so and i talk about this often
because i think a lot of founders get
caught up in that sort of ego or like
i'm the founder i'm here i deserve to be
in this role and i want to be the chief
whatever
and for us it's always been this a very
open throne relationship of like
we're not here to take on the world
we're here to build a business and
whatever we have to do like we'll bring
in the best people possible to do it
yeah and that has happened many times in
the company but
one of the key things that now looking
back i think we did really well mateona
in terms of bringing our
doing this business together and then we
had the relationship was that we don't
think about this company and it
certainly isn't it's not a family
business so it's not
our family company right
and that reflects in a few things first
is the fact that
even though now we very openly talk
about the fact that we are a couple
it wasn't something we made part of the
identity of the company early on
right we didn't want people to just know
us because of that and
we also had other co-founders and so
having
other people around certainly helped
because it wasn't just the two of us
and then lastly bringing other
executives into the business as soon as
they were needed in as early as possible
so that at that point also one of the
things matteo talks a lot about is that
um it's not there's no distinction
between the founders and the executives
other than potentially ownership of the
business and like maybe have seat at the
board right but
we should we're all executives here we
all have a function
that we have to fulfill and we should
all be judged in the same way
we shouldn't get special treatment just
because you were here earlier you're the
founder
and that all of those things have
certainly helped in terms of
professionalizing the relationship
between i have because at the end of the
day he's the ceo
and i lead growth and marketing so he's
my boss i report to him
and so then the other things we started
doing was how do we manage our
one-on-ones how do we manage
the conversations when they're easier or
they're tough in terms of making
decisions between
the ceo and the head of marketing right
so as much as we can just treating it in
the same way that he does with everyone
else
so you cannot bring those conversations
the dinner table because you're not
having that conversation with someone
else at their dinner table when you talk
to joe ronda who's your head of ops
right you don't go into his dinner table
and start asking him things about work
um obviously for us it spills over into
many more hours of the day because we
love what we do we talk about work all
the time
but there are certain moments where we
try to keep it just separate
because we have to otherwise the
relationship would suffer
yeah and uh i think you guys have said
this publicly before uh
what what is this saying like on
whatsapp she's my wife on slack she's my
co-founder yeah right
yeah we're using separate channels
separate channels and
it almost is like you're putting
yourself in a different mindset right in
terms of how you're going to talk to
somebody
uh but it feels like that has been
really beneficial and actually made this
not only work from a work perspective
but also
um you know from a relationship
standpoint right it also like
provides this environment that allows
you to be husband and wife not
co-founders
yeah i mean you know when you're
building a business your business is
everything so i'm also always honest
about that like you probably think
both of us are thinking about business
all the time so
you have to think about your
relationship too and like how you
maintain that
because it's just as important so
they're both going to take work
and for us it's been very beneficial
actually to
do this together we always think like i
don't know if we would still be here
with the relationship we have if we're
not building the company together
because it's been a lot of years it's
been a lot of ups
and downs and that ability to understand
each other right like
if he needs to take a call like any
second no matter what we're doing no
matter how important it is for personal
life i know exactly why
it matters to the business right now i
don't even need to ask i know what he's
going through
and he knows the same for me and so it's
been an asset
instead of a liability even though a lot
of people talk about like oh you don't
want to invest in
people who are related and companies
that are you know founded by people who
are married because what if they break
up
actually there's no plan b for people
who are building things together the
whole family is invested in that there's
no no one else's salary or no one else's
company is the backup
that's it and so you're giving it all i
uh
work with my wife obviously and many of
my brothers
and we joke all the time like literally
my brother will walk in the room
we can talk [ __ ] to each other we can go
at it
and then two minutes later like you want
to go get lunch right and it's just like
there's um there's this like uh there's
no walking away
yeah like no matter what we say to each
other or do or whatever like
you're still gonna be my brother and so
what ends up happening is you almost
like
get over the like social awkwardness and
like when people first come around us
and they see it they're like oh my god
right
like i grew up with these guys like
literally we have fist fought
many many times over the years well
that's another thing too is that these
people know you better
than anyone else and so i find that to
be
one of the most challenging parts in a
good way because
with mateo as my manager no one knows me
better in the world right now than he
does
yep and so he's able to push my buttons
in all the right way also in the wrong
ways but i find it
to be a positive because i want to be
challenged i want to grow
and i can do the same with him if he's
facing a problem i know what's going
through his mind what he's thinking what
worries him what concerns him and so
you become a great compliment because
you know each other in a personal way
which is something you always want to
you know get to know when you're working
with someone when you're managing
someone who are developing them and it's
hard to do most people won't open up
mm-hmm so you have that already like you
know yourself which is honesty
you can be honest and i feel like most
people aren't honest with each other
yeah
right uh speaking of honesty one of the
investors that you guys have is keith
roboy
uh who by all accounts is one of the
best investors
probably in history in uh technology i
can't believe i'm saying this because
he might tweet that quote um but
he's always honest right he's very
direct uh and i think that that's
off-putting to some people but
actually founders that he works with um
and people who really respect him see
that as like one of the superpowers that
he has
uh what is it like working with him and
like what have you guys learned from him
oh yeah he was
definitely honest i can definitely think
a lot of times in board meetings when he
has said things
it's always respectful so i appreciate
that but i
what i like about the honesty is similar
to what i was describing with
your manager knowing you is that it
pushes you
it challenges you to think right when
someone tells you something's really
good or something's mediocre
and you are able to take that in in the
right way
and process it then you'll come out the
other side doing things much better
i think that's what we have seen um in
our relationship with keith in the
past years which has have been quite a
few and
it there's been so many times when his
feedback has been crucial in terms of
just how we're approaching different
sides of the business
and it feels like uh you guys
and keith work so well together because
when he's honest you guys
understand that he's being honest
because he really cares about the
success of the business yeah right
it would be easy for somebody to get
forget keith for a second just anyone
being you know honest with them
and they get offended 100 right and
instead it's like no actually we're all
on the same team here right and so like
we need that honesty right you and
matteo have it you guys have it with
keith other investors etc
um last question before we get into the
rapid fire is miami you guys are here
yes full time uh you moved in
when august of last year yeah we started
like around a year ago we started coming
here yeah and then
permanent move was yeah like november
okay november
uh one pro one con of miami so far
oh my god there's there's definitely a
lot of pros i've been loving it i was
worried that i would miss new york but
it's been great
um biggest pro i definitely have to say
the sunshine
because i had a lot of issues in new
york when like you had gray days
and it would definitely affect my mood
and i feel like here i'm just much more
energized i want to do things
i work more just you know good or bad it
just gives me more energy so i really
really
appreciate the sunshine that is here in
florida
year round one con
chinese food i haven't found really good
chinese food
so i am missing that and there are a
handful but there are not as many as you
would find in your experience have you
heard about the chinese food taste test
that i did
no i went to uh he posted this was fine
uh shervin pisivar and i
had lunch and uh he ordered a bunch of
different chinese foods and literally it
was like
okay this is chinese food location a b c
whatever
and we tried them all we were trying to
figure out what the best one is because
nobody knows
what is the best chinese food in miami
so if you were out there and you know
good chinese food in miami please let us
know i have a whole group of friends
that are looking for
100 um all right three questions then
you could ask me one to finish uh most
important book you've ever read
oh
i'd probably say when breath becomes
air oh that's a great one because when i
read it my dad had just passed away
and so it just became kind of like i was
young when he passed away and i think it
really
shaped me and how i think about spending
a bit more time
with family and like people you love and
like the process that people
may be going through as they know
they're going to die soon like it was
just
this very it just meant so much to me to
read something from
that other side and realizing i maybe
should have made more questions and had
more conversations and wanted to make
sure that like
that doesn't happen with other people in
my life before they leave yeah that's a
great answer
i love that book uh uh second question
is your sleep schedule
i usually ask people about their sleep
schedule
you said eight to nine hours yes uh what
else do you do other than sleep on
the mattress and pod uh in terms of
trying to get good sleep
yeah it very so i don't drink alcohol um
and then it varies kind of
the tips and tricks maybe sometimes i'll
do some cbd melatonin gummies
if i'm just like feeling like i cannot
unplug in the evening so i'll do that
maybe an hour before
i go to bed and it definitely helps
relax um
i use my phone up until the last second
like i'm in bed so
i you know it's hard to tell people not
to do it so i do it but
if you can avoid the tv i actually find
the tv to be much more stimulating
um so just you know try to turn off the
tv 10 minutes before go to bed relax
read a book
maybe read on your phone but um just the
consumption of like media and shows and
news can be very stressful in the
evening
got it and then uh the cbd melatonin
is just like that's kind of like
something that's soothing that then puts
you to sleep yes
got it uh third question is aliens are
you a believer or non-believer oh god
i'm definitely a believer
i mean there has to be something else
out there in the universe come on
yeah do you think that we'll ever come
in contact with them i think so
really yeah oh see i think either
because they're coming here we're going
there
i mean if we want to go and colonize
mars like eventually do you think
there's mainly
there well maybe somewhere else yeah
mark the whole mars thing
uh i've said for a long time like that
thing's so big like how do we know if
there's water or not or whatever
and now like over the last two or three
years like we've got a helicopter that
people are flying there
like they found some ice right like
they're somehow being able to turn the
air into oxygen like
there's just you can see like oh wait
there's a lot more here than people
really realized and so
uh i'm much more bullish i think on mars
colonization than people yeah and
actually sleep's going to be a big
challenge in mars why because the day
length is different
and so adjusting our circadian cycles to
interesting that and mars is going to be
a challenge and then there's the other
thing of like getting people
there and there's like trying to get
people into a state of like
sleep so like only putting you to sleep
so that you make the journey and then
like waking you up there like there's
all these interesting things and they've
been studying sleep
nasa has been for a while now and see
like it's going to be a challenge
so apparently people who are the night
owls are going to be able to adjust
better interesting
the sleeping on the way there is what it
takes probably a couple days to get
there yeah i don't know if a couple or
more
but yeah definitely weeks right so like
would they like put
like drug you to go to sleep or just
like hey
sleep wake up like screw around in the
spaceship but it's hard right because
like we are um our our cycle
is is so much determined by
the sun like we're creatures of nature
and so what happens when you get us out
of there like you probably have to have
some technology
maybe a pod who knows that is getting
into those cycles of light exposure that
you need so that you can get in and out
of
waking and sleep cycles for the duration
of the trip
um yeah there's like a lot of those
considerations but it's interesting
sleep is one of those unsolved pieces
for humans to be able to adapt
to mars because you could bring food you
could do a lot of other things but
how do you make sure that our
metabolisms adjust
is is a big one ate sleep sleeping for
mars
they got a new tagline uh what question
do you have for me to end this
what are you most excited about for this
year
most excited for this year um
i don't know there's so much uh
i would say just spending time with
friends and family like
i feel like after the last 12 months or
so everyone is just like
dude this was crazy right and some
people
still saw their family a little bit some
saw them not at all
uh some people literally like left
wherever they lived and moved back home
or whatever
so everyone had a different experience
but i think just like getting back to
normal
a little bit of like whenever you want
to go see somebody you can and you don't
have to worry about like
oh is there a flight there oh do i have
to wear a mask oh do i have to
make sure that i have a vaccination or
like like once we get
kind of past all this and it's just more
of like okay alex like what do you want
to do do you want to go somewhere do you
want to see somebody like you can do
that you have to worry about the
restrictions
i feel like that it'll just kind of like
feel like okay like like we're past
all of this yeah um and then you just
get to enjoy life i agree i just saw my
family after a year and a half so
definitely felt that
yeah it's been a while it's better i
went back to tijuana to visit them so
yeah it was
do they have eight sleep pods uh my
sister does cause she's in l.a
okay um but my my mom still lives in
mexico so she was just asking me for one
earlier
oh we got mom converting as i was there
and i was sleeping in her bed with her
and i'm like this bed sucks you gotta
get a pond
[Laughter]
i love it uh where can people find you
on the internet or find a sleep
twitter twitter is definitely the place
find me i'm easy to find there and
aidsleep.com if you wanna know anything
about our products go get it eight sleep
i sleep on it every night it's amazing
my brother actually i think yeah my
brother has uh one of them for sure
and uh the first night he slept on he
sent me a screenshot of the app
and it said 100 sleep score and he was
like like you know i'm the best like
whatever and i was like dude
everyone says that the first night and
then he was like wait really
so adam convinced for a while that he
wasn't a good sleeper that it was just
like a
a bug in the app but uh it was just to
get you excited the first night yeah oh
and then you get into it and then you
want to keep up
then the next night it's 60 all right
asleep.com thank you so much for doing
this thank you i'll do it again